- I'm just letting y'all
know y'all beautiful, okay?
(girls laugh)
Just.
- We know.
- Okay. Just making sure.
But I gotta be brutally honest somehow.
(upbeat music)
- [Speaker 1] If you had to
rank yourself against others
based on a specific trait,
what would it say about how you see them
(bell chimes)
and how they see you?
We brought together five couples
and had the girlfriends rank themselves
based on how attractive
they think they are.
Then, we invited their
boyfriends to rearrange them.
This is Ranking.
- Hi, my name is Ajanea.
I'm 23 and I'm a Mindset
Coach from Sacramento.
- Hi guys, I'm Vera.
I am 23 and I am a PhD student.
- Whoa.
(girls laugh)
You win.
- I'm Sophia.
I'm 19 and I'm a full
time college student.
- Woo-hoo.
- Yeah!
- I'm Jennifer.
I'm 26. I'm a property manager and also
upcoming real estate agent as well.
- Yeah!
- Boss woman.
- I'm Sky.
I'm 21. I'm a full-time student,
and I'm also getting my
Pilates certification.
- Woo.
(girls clap)
- I would define attractiveness
by something that it
makes your body feel like
are you attracted to the person
or does it kind of make
you repel from them?
- If you have a great personality,
you're fun, energetic.
- Having some sort of direction.
- Yeah.
- I think it's more than physicality.
I think how they carry themselves,
self care, hygiene, how they smell.
(girls laugh)
- Yeah, hygiene's a big one.
- No stinky.
- Yes, no stinky people.
- Yeah.
- My boyfriend met me in college
and he always tells this
story about how he saw me
like across from the library,
- [Sophia] Aww.
- And was like, oh my God,
look at this stunner,
which obviously I am.
- Yeah.
(girls laugh)
- He's always been like a
little bit of a shy boy.
So he never like really
went up to me or anything.
So we met
(bell chimes)
officially on Tinder.
- Ooh.
- So yes I definitely think he thinks
that I'm attractive or at least I hope so.
(girls laugh)
- For sure.
- So my boyfriend hit me up, in his words,
"I slid in her DM's."
(girls laugh)
That's what he said.
I believe he does think I'm attractive.
(girls laugh)
And he's the one who did the first move.
So, we're gonna go with yes.
(girls laugh)
- We were coworkers at The Burger Saloon,
and right off like I was the one,
the most prettiest at my job.
(girls laugh)
- I mean, we first met on Tinder.
He super liked me.
(bell chimes)
- Woo!
(girls laugh)
- So I'm assuming that he
was attracted. (laughs)
Here we are now five
and a half years later.
- Aw, MVP's.
(girls laugh)
- Yeah.
- We met in high school,
he complimented my shoes.
- Ooh.
- He was like, "I like your shoes."
I was like, "I know."
(girls laugh)
But, I friend zoned him at first.
- Oh.
- So it took us a while to get here,
but like one and a half year strong.
- Yeah.
(girls clap)
- I mean, I think everyone here is like
definitely like really attractive.
- Yeah, I think we're all
very confident in who we are.
- Yeah.
- And that's already attractive
right there sometimes.
- Yes.
(upbeat music)
- Okay.
(girls laugh)
- Okay. First off. No one's a five here.
I think we're all attractive women here.
- Yeah. Should we start with outfits?
- Yes.
- I like her outfit.
- The jacket.
(girls laugh)
- And your hair's gorgeous.
- Yeah, come up here.
- Your makeups on point.
- Well, I believe you need
to come with me, though.
- Okay. No, for sure.
- Cause it's giving like Olivia Rodrigo.
- Ooh!
- Very true. Very much so.
Okay. Okay.
- Your nails are super cool too, so.
- Yeah, get that.
- The attention to detail, like the beads,
the necklace, the rings.
- Yeah, okay.
Maybe tattoos.
'Cause I've been seeing
your guys' tattoos.
- I'll be at the end.
- Oh, I don't have a tattoo.
- You don't have a tattoo.
- Yeah, what,
so like, are tattoos,
- Are they attractive?
- Are they attractive on girls?
- [Ajanea] Yeah.
- Oh, I think so.
- I think they're attractive.
- I think I have some like,
a lot of stupid tattoos.
(girls laugh)
Like I have a math integral on my back.
It's like really nerdy.
- I think you should be over here.
- Yeah.
- I feel like
you're Miss Stallion.
- [Ajanea] Yeah.
(girls laugh)
- With the height, the hair, everything.
- The build.
- The PhD,
- Yeah.
- Everything.
- Okay.
- Like you played soccer
growing up or something.
Ooh, volleyball.
- Yeah.
Are you athletic? That's attractive too.
- I almost went to the Olympics
for both ice skating and skiing.
- I go to the gym for mental clarity and
just to get my physical
appearance up there, you know?
- [Sky] I salute you to that.
- That's actually really-.
- Gym's scare me.
- Oh my God, they do.
- The men.
(girls laugh)
- Okay.
- Personality. Okay.
- Yes.
- If it was personality,
I'd put you up there.
- Girl you gotta be up top, like.
You are character in a good way.
(girls laugh)
You two definitely go up.
- Yeah.
- I'm definitely more of a quiet, shy,
- I know, I'm one of the introverts too.
- I just talk a lot.
(girls laugh)
Don't get it confused.
- [Sophia] It's good though.
You have such a pretty smile.
- No, but yours is a pretty smile too.
- So why?
- And so is yours
and you have a more right
here, which is kind of cute.
(girls laugh)
- You know, I'm just looking at accents.
- You scare me.
- What?
- 'Cause you're so pretty.
- Oh my God, girl stop. I'm
like sunburn, turning red.
(girls laugh)
- And I freaking love your body, so.
- Yeah. I wish I had your legs.
Are you kidding me?
- Yeah.
- I'm literally built like a Corgi.
(girls laugh)
- You're up there.
- Yeah.
- I'll switch with you.
- No!
(girls laugh)
- Me too.
- No, no, no, girl, you up there.
- Okay.
(Ajanea claps)
- [Speaker 1] Alright,
now why don't you guys now
take an average kinda mix
personality and overall looks.
And that will be your final ranking.
- Alright.
- I think you're definitely
number one for me.
- Yeah.
- Love you guys.
- No question to that.
- I think,
- Number two. I swear. Yeah.
- [Vera] Get back here, girl.
(girls laugh)
- I think you're good at three.
- Yeah. Is it?
- I was expecting myself to be number five
not because I don't
think highly of myself,
but just 'cause I was on a, I don't know,
like on set with all these beautiful women
and they all have something
going on in their lives too.
I just feel like I'm okay
with what they set me at.
(Jennifer laughs)
- I don't know, guys.
- You know what? I have an idea.
We can hold hands and
then we're all number one.
(girls laugh)
(timer beeps)
- There we go.
- We're a message.
- We're connected.
- Send a message.
- Yeah.
(chill music)
- Least to most, I would say
least, I'll do at the end,
the turtleneck, just 'cause not my style.
Two, her, 'cause I don't like tall girls.
- That's valid.
- That's so brutal.
- [Kalvin] Three, four, and then five.
- I think I'd go five with the blue socks
just 'cause she is tall
and I'm like five, seven.
I'll go 4, 3, 2, 1.
(bell chimes)
(guys laugh)
- I'll just start from one.
I'm gonna say one.
Yeah,
(guys laughing)
Two, I do like the Pilates thing.
I think that's actually really cool.
Three. She's getting a PhD,
which is really cool, actually.
Four. I think she's super sweet
and then five. Nothing
against you, just not my type.
She's still really cool though.
Has a great bubbly personality.
- I'll start from five.
I think she's great.
Has a great personality's.
It's just not something
that I think I find as
attractive in particular.
Four, she has like a
really cute turtleneck.
She's very sweet.
Three, And then two, she has some sort of
Kardashian vibe going on.
(guys laughing)
- That's what I said.
And then one, like obviously
my girlfriend, you know.
(Ryan laughs)
- I would say number five would be her.
Not my type. Love the hair though.
Number four, I would say it would be her.
She's a little bit on the quiet side.
Number three, I would say her
'cause she's a little too
tall for me, I would say.
Maybe a lot taller than I am. (laughs)
I love her style.
Love the long jacket and of
course number, what was I?
- It's like five
- Number five.
- There you go.
Yeah, number five, I
would say would be you,
not only because she's my girlfriend
but because I just love simple.
- Yeah.
- And that's what made me,
yeah. Choose that. (laughs)
(upbeat music)
I'm just letting y'all
know y'all beautiful, okay?
(girls laugh)
Just.
- We know.
- Okay, just making sure.
But I gotta be brutally honest somehow.
As for number one, she
would be that one person
I would go to if I need any support,
any love and I like simplicity.
Number two, I love the fit.
Number three, cool socks. (laughs)
Number four, she's pretty cool too.
And number five, pretty cool also.
You know, it's just not my type.
No hard feelings, though, y'all.
(girls laugh)
Number one, we have a
very special connection.
Probably one of the most beautiful, caring
and really amazing person.
- That's not me.
(Ryan laughs)
- Two. I think she has
a cool Kardashian look.
Three as well. Good looking,
but a bit, you know,
on the shyer end.
Four, she seems like a very caring person
and five, not quite my vibe,
but great personality as well.
- For number one, absolutely adore her.
And I think she's the most
beautiful girl in the world
and she's like the most
free-thinking person
I've ever met in my life.
And then two, she seems
very mature for her age.
Three, she's also very intelligent,
and four, she's super sweet.
She kind of knows her place
and who she is and is very confident.
Five, also, I would say
not my type necessarily
but I love the confidence
and I love how she's herself completely.
And I think that's really cool.
- Pick number one, no explanation needed.
One, the best, you know.
Number two, she looks like Olivia Rodrigo.
I put number three, 'cause
personality is cool.
Is really chill. She's a vibe.
And number four just 'cause she's simple.
And I like what she said she was doing
for a living and stuff.
And then number five,
just put it at the bottom.
You know, not my type,
but she's really smart.
So, that's cool too.
- So, number one, it's a little biased,
but this woman is super divine
and deserves all my time.
Two, I like her outfit and her hair.
Three, kind of the same.
Four, this person's like
athletic and motivated
and then five, no certain reason,
just someone's gotta go last.
(upbeat cheerful music)
- [Speaker 1] Ajanea,
you switch with Jennifer.
Jennifer, you can switch with Vera.
(girls laugh)
Vera, you can switch with Sophia.
And then, Sophia, you can switch with Sky.
And this was the average ranking.
- No.
(girls laughing)
- Seems like a guy's choice.
(girls laugh)
- I feel like, I don't,
you know, this needs to.
(Jennifer laughs)
- Placing me last caught me off guard.
- Yeah.
- I don't think I should be here. (laughs)
- [Speaker 1] Were you surprised?
- Kinda. Yeah.
I'm not really sure what the
guys factored in to get there
but I think that the
girls have like a more
open heartedly perspective.
- Me being in the middle
also makes sense because
I'm also a little bit more on
the stereotypical attractiveness.
Like I have blonde hair, I'm tall.
Just kind of all these
things that, you know,
you grow up hearing about like what is
considered attractive.
- We're all beautiful.
- Yeah.
- I was gonna say we're all beautiful.
- [Sophia] Yeah.
- No one deserves to be a number five.
- Yeah.
I don't think the ranking is
based even on attractiveness.
I think,
- Yeah.
- We just got put in our places.
- I'm not taking anything personally.
Oh yeah. I still think I'm cute.
I'm not that attractive, but, (laughs)
- Damn right, baby.
- I still think
I'm a decent girl, or woman.
- Damn right.
- You know, you win some, you lose some.
(Ajanea claps and laughs)
Not everyone thinks you're a hottie.
(Ajanea laughs)